today we're talking about workspace
webinars subsea cables the how and whys
of ai
and ubuntu pro i'm carter morgan and
welcome to this week in cloud where we
serve you
the lowest latency news whether your
team is heading back to the office or
exploring a variety of hybrid models
google workspace will help you adapt and
make the most of it
over the past year we've announced a
variety of updates to google workspace
from companion mode to hybrid
collaboration tools
sign up for our free upcoming webinar on
july 28th to learn more for mena an open
subsea cable
will run from the east coast of the us
to argentina with the digital landings
in brazil and uruguay
firmino will be the longest cable in the
world capable of running entirely from a
single power source at one end of the
cable
if its other power sources become
temporarily unavailable a resilience
boost at a time when reliable
connectivity is more important than ever
many companies today are actively using
ai or have plans to incorporate it into
their future strategies
but as ai and advanced analytics become
more pervasive the need for more
transparency around how ai technology
works will be paramount
decision makers want to know the reasons
behind an ai-based decision
so they have the confidence that it's
the right one check out the blog to
learn more about why and how you need to
explain ml models
we're pleased to announce the general
availability of ubuntu pro images on
google cloud
providing customers with an improved
ubuntu experience expanded security
coverage and integration with critical
google cloud features
in partnership with canonical we're
making it even easier for customers that
have fully embraced open source
to ensure security and compliance for
their most mission-critical enterprise
workloads
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us
and we'll see you in the cloud